use but we're going to treat it more
like a homolateral salt
okay he has
like hom okay
hom and you're doing Jon Jon okay so
he's coming here I don't let him touch
it
home
for
[Music]
have to do that other
way I going stay here block this and
move
that I to
yield
[Music]
it it of course looks like like uh I'm
moving to the
outside and then uh do the shoulder so
I'm moving this and I push him like that
okay
um but uh you're going to see if I push
him like this then I can't really do the
entry if I would have enter normally I'd
be over
here
okay uh you going to pay attention to
your hands okay so I and going to reach
for contact and this time is going to do
a spiral
here that's makes me go from the
outside to the inside you see and as I
continue you're going to see that that
hand is almost there on his
head so
outside there it is right there all I
got to do is that small entering
and then it was on
the Outside Inside there it is my and I
enter and it continues its inward
spiral Outside Inside I enter and
continues the inward spiral
again Outside Inside I enter there's the
see
that in there this one is not going to
go like
this it's going to
go slow down it's going to go this
way
this inward
spiral inward spiral two
and so when I do this step to bring that
hand on this knife
edge is going to turn into this
check
good again you're now paying attention
to the second hand a little slower so
you can
see this hand doesn't go from my right
to my
left this hand goes and this one goes in
this
way but I rotate around
it and that's what gives it that outward
appearance but my hands are in essence
slow slow war
war doing
that and he's falling
into oh the wave right
there
boom I'm on the
outside letting him pass I'm going this
way letting him
pass all I got make sure that I'm not
where he can
grab but I don't want to be a million
miles away I want to lead him into his
attempt that's what I
look and lead them in
[Music]
oh much
tighter there it
is
start so far away
grab
oh
I want to tell you once and for
all that if you
use your
arms to
work two points of a
lever it is
incorrect there's only one single pivot
point and it is his
spine okay so I he comes in oh you're
not going to hook here do you see that
not going to hook here and use these two
points to turn
them you will not do I'm On Top I'm
didn't hook it I didn't hook it Sensei
I'm on top or maybe I'm grabbing and you
come around
here the only way you can do that is you
start breaking all kinds of other
correct forms so if I here and I can use
this lever then my Center is in the
middle of my hands and I am not in back
of him I'm on the side of
him oh he's going to go by me and I'll
show you how he goes by
me okay so you have the first yield but
he's trying to grab we're stuck okay and
when I do the kazushi it's moving him
with the adhesion
boom then the other hand picks it up the
other hand is going to pick up that
adhesion uh on the turn so I am going to
add to it and that turn
that so one I'm bringing him in I'm
bringing him around on the
turn because I want to get in the back
and right now his back is not
accessible
see you're going to do
this well when you start turning you're
not in the back of him and you do this
so I'm going to yield I'm going to bring
him in oh and I'm going to step
here behind him Bo bringing him
inow
okay so I need to be in the back not
have my Center between my two hands one
hand on his neck and one hand on his
wrist
also what I'm doing here
is
uh you you you would smell he's so close
he's so
close so if I just go here this
superficial surface contest a contact he
can go over and
grab but if I have the
adhesion he he will not find that easy
he can't get off of that
friction he
goes I'm just passing it same thing he
can't go out either oh he's stuck into
it
oh so when you see the contact on his
arm when I come around here it's the
same thing I'm not just here touching
him here it's stuck so as he goes
forward he's feeling huge friction
that's why we're stuck together and as I
move around we're going to see that this
hand picks up that Ike
adhesion just like this hand has
adhesion and it starts to go and now
it's going to go off you see that's why
Kitty gash works like that over here but
now this hand is going to pick it up
before that happens now this hand is
sticking here okay and now as you go
around and you enter behind him you're
going to find that it's hard to do the
adhesion there it went past its Yin
phase that's where this hand comes in so
he tries to go forward and he can't go
forward you're just bringing that
around which means this hand can't be
used for your little pulling and things
why is that
important because eventually I'm going
to lose that hand and any UK that keeps
contact here they did it
themselves he's he's pushing back on me
he's pushing I don't have I don't have
anything here you see he's pushing on me
pull your hand off I can't stop that
from there do you see that so you all
have your Uka that's just in this
cultural form and then you use
that so here I have this arm here I have
his arm now I'm going to lose his arm he
pulls his arm in it doesn't matter to me
I still have his
Center so we're going to make you pull
pull your arm in doesn't matter doesn't
matter to me cuz I never I never used it
to take his kazushi to take him into
this
kazushi
this is
different move and here and here it's
off and he boom andion comes on
the no he does he can take his arm back
doesn't matter doesn't
matter you a good fighter would you know
stick to you you're making them stick to
you they don't culturally stick to you
okay
okay so if you look at the first inward
spiral I was on the inside but by
continuing it I get to the outside you
see and the second inward spiral looks
like it is going the wrong way you see
that but because my body turns in the
opposite direction it will do your
outward movement that you want you see
when you turn your body that wrong way
is doing the outward movement that you
want all this to tell you that a circle
a circular movement that is going left
is actually going right and one that is
going forward is actually going
backwards backwards is going forward and
right is going left okay so when you
think I'm taking them backwards you need
to do your circle forward not backwards
okay so I'll get us to the point at the
end okay so we're over here and you
picture that I am taking him backwards
into this
kazushi so he's going to get up and
you're going to turn him he's starting
to turn towards me if you pay attention
and look how easy this is oh that sucks
okay but what your choreograph few kid
does is they stay like
that what we're going to do instead is
as he goes up as he's starting to go up
I'm bringing him forward into it I'm
bringing him forward into it I'll do but
with his
head back over here he's going forward
into that
Circle he's going to get up and I'm
going bring him
forward I can move if I want
forward
backwards forward and around
[Music]
forward backwards into
it
Forward into
[Music]
forward
forward and
around over in Round One Direction not
down
back
forward make the circle he's now going
backwards okay try